hagamos otro ejemplo en el que lanzamos
algo que cae a un nivel diferente y
vamos a calcular otras cosas
interesantes Como por ejemplo el vector
velocidad cuando cae este objeto tanto
su magnitud como su dirección digamos
que vamos a lanzar algo a nivel del
suelo y va a haber una plataforma Algo
elevado vamos a lanzar nuestro objeto a
un ángulo pues bastante elevado vamos a
lanzar nuestro objeto nuestro proyectil
con un ángulo de 80 grados
y va a ser lanzado con una velocidad de
30 metros sobre segundo y pues cuando
caiga va a caer en algún punto en esta
plataforma Quiero saber qué tan lejos
por encima de esta plataforma va a
llegar el objeto esta plataforma tiene
una altura desde la base del suelo
de 10 metros
Bueno entonces
Ah también otra información otro dato es
que la distancia desde donde hago el
lanzamiento hasta donde comienza la
plataforma es de 2 metros ahora sí que
mi dibujo no está hecho a escala Pero
bueno
Estas son las mediciones para que
trabajemos con ellas en el problema
entonces bueno igual que hemos hecho
antes vamos a descomponer este vector
velocidad en sus elementos horizontales
y verticales vamos a resolverlo de
manera más rápida Ya que en vídeos
anteriores hemos visto detalle el uso de
las funciones trigonométricas para
calcular o para encontrar estos
elementos entonces este es nuestro
vector velocidad su magnitud es de 30
metros sobre segundo su ángulo es de 80
grados y queremos encontrar su
componente horizontal
más o menos por acá y su componente
vertical
que es más o menos por acá
Entonces como Este es un triángulo
rectángulo aquí Esta es un ángulo recto
podemos usar las funciones
trigonométricas Si queremos conocer el
la magnitud de su componente horizontal
de este vector velocidad
esto va a ser igual a el cateto opuesto
perdón a hipotenusa o el valor de 30 no
voy a usar los
las unidades para ahorrar espacio
30 por el cateto opuesto sobre
hipotenusa entonces va a ser la función
seno por el seno de el ángulo que es 80
grados esta Va a ser mi magnitud del
vector o de la componente vertical con
respecto a la componente horizontal su
magnitud
de la componente horizontal de la
velocidad va a ser igual igual a la
hipotenusa o el valor de 30 multiplicado
por el en este caso es el coseno porque
es el cateto adyacente al ángulo coseno
de 80 grados aquí están las magnitudes
de estos valores con esto quiero yo
calcular cuánto tiempo pasó mi proyectil
en el aire
bueno en los videos anteriores usamos la
fórmula del desplazamiento
esta fórmula del desplazamiento y nos
referimos al desplazamiento vertical voy
a ponerle subíndice G que es nada más el
desplazamiento hacia arriba o hacia
abajo que tuvo mi proyectil es igual a
mi velocidad inicial
multiplicado por el cambio en el tiempo
más
la aceleración vamos a ponerla en otro
color verdecito la aceleración vertical
por el cambio en el tiempo
al cuadrado
todo esto entre dos
conocemos la velocidad inicial que es
pues nuestro vector pero nuestra
componente vertical de la velocidad Este
es mi velocidad inicial y tengo la
aceleración vertical que es la
aceleración de la gravedad recordando
nuestra convención de que las vectores
hacia arriba con dirección hacia arriba
se denotan con cantidades positivas y
los vectores que se dirigen hacia abajo
tendrán una cantidad negativa
por lo que esta aceleración como es la
aceleración de la gravedad va hacia
abajo va a tener una una cantidad
negativa Así que nuestro desplazamiento
vertical
es igual a mi velocidad inicial que es
esta
es
30 lo voy a poner el mismo color de la
literal para que se vea 30 por el seno
de 80 grados
multiplicado por el camión el tiempo
más la aceleración que la aceleración
por ser hacia abajo es menos
9.8 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
Pero bueno aquí no lo estoy tomando o
poniendo las unidades multiplicado por
el cambio del tiempo
al cuadrado
entre dos
este desplazamiento
aquí tenemos que bueno al inicio es cero
o se lo estamos lanzando desde nivel del
suelo y cuando caiga va a caer con una
diferencia de distancia de 10 metros
Entonces mi desplazamiento es de 10
metros
me queda bueno la magnitud de este
desplazamiento y su dirección
son 10 metros es igual a
30 seno de 80 grados
por el cambio en el tiempo
y aquí va a ser menos
9.8 entre 2 es 4.9
Delta t al cuadrado para resolver esto
vamos a usar
las la fórmula para encontrar las raíces
de una ecuación cuadrática y bueno vamos
a dejar esto de esta fórmula ahora sí
que en el formato de una ecuación
cuadrática entonces va a quedar
menos 4.9
del tate al cuadrado
más 30
seno de 80 grados del tatem
menos 10
y todo esto va a ser igual a cero y así
ya tenemos el término de mis ecuaciones
cuadráticas recordamos la fórmula Este
término o esta parte Yo le voy a llamar
a de hecho Vamos a ponerle otro color
para que sea más representativo
esto es término lo voy a llamar a
este otro será
b y este otro será c hay otros videos
donde se explican esta función
cuadrática para obtener las raíces pero
en este caso les pongo que para
encontrar las raíz del tate
es la fórmula
menos B
más menos raíz cuadrada
de B cuadrada menos
4 por
estoy poniendo los colores
correspondientes a
por C
todo esto dividido
entre 2 a
sustituyendo estos valores en esta
fórmula para obtener las raíces voy a
tener que mi cambio en el tiempo
va a ser igual menos B
menos
30 seno de 80 grados
más menos la raíz cuadrada de cualquier
cosa elevado al cuadrado va a ser una
cantidad positiva entonces Este voy a
ponerlo a que es cantidad positiva 30
seno de 80
al cuadrado menos
4 por a es menos 4.9
4 * a es
menos
4.9 multiplicado por C
se es menos 10
- 10
y es la raíz cuadrada de todo esto
dividido entre dos veces a
y ya viene siendo
2 por A menos 4.9
menos 4.9 Ok Aquí voy a tener dos
valores dos raíces Tengo que asegurarme
de que la raíz de o el valor de cambio
en el tiempo sea un valor positivo
en nuestra realidad un tiempo negativo
no tiene mucho sentido porque es como si
estuviéramos regresando en el pasado
realmente algo que pues no no tiene
sentido para nosotros en nuestra
realidad y en nuestra dimensión entonces
para asegurarme que esta cantidad sea
positiva si yo me doy cuenta en el
numerador y en el denominador al menos
en el denominador se está sé que esta
cantidad es negativa para que este valor
sea positivo esta cantidad en el
numerador tiene que ser negativa también
para que ambos símbolos negativos en el
numerador y en el denominador se cancela
el mutuamente y me quedé una cantidad
positiva Así que voy a resolver para los
valores con esta raíz negativa o sea
estos valores menos para garantizar
que ambos lados o bueno ambas partes
numerador y denominador son negativos y
se cancelan para que dé una cantidad
final positiva Aquí vamos a irnos paso a
paso
Vamos a calcular primero estos elementos
es
menos 4 por menos 4.9 bueno estos signos
menos se van a cancelar van a volverse
positivos pero a su vez esto lo voy a
multiplicar con el signo negativo
entonces va a quedar una cantidad
negativa Entonces 4.9 por 10 es 49 49
por 4
49 por 4
196 entonces aquí me queda menos
el seno
30 por seno de
80 grados
a 30 por seno
80 grados el seno de 80 grados es esto
lo multiplico por 30
29.54 vamos a notar
por acá 29 puntos 54 sí
es
29.54 al cuadrado entonces va a ser
29.54
al cuadrado y de esto después voy a
sacar la raíz cuadrada
y la voy a hacer restada con este valor
de -30 seno de 80 grados que calculamos
este este valor
menos
29.54 y Esto va a ser dividido entre
2 por 4.9 va a ser 9.8 y este va a ser
mi cambio en el tiempo así que sigamos
haciendo los cálculos aquí paso a paso
esto voy a elevarlo al cuadrado
lo voy a restar el 196 que calculé aquí
y esto lo voy a sacar la raíz cuadrada
26 entonces va a ser
menos 26
.01
menos
26.01 Y esto es menos
29.54 menos más menos estas se van a
sumar y Aquí lo tengo menos 9.8
es mi del
tatem ahora sí que para no confundirnos
estoy anotando paso a paso todos los las
operaciones
esto
más 29.54
es igual a menos
55.55 entre
9.8
esta Delta t es igual a
valor positivo de lo que calculamos
5.67 vamos a redondearlo
5.67 segundos es el tiempo que tardó mi
proyectil en el aire antes de volver a
caer y bueno ya tenemos este valor ahora
para qué voy a usar esta cantidad en el
tiempo lo vamos a usar para saber qué
tan lejos llegó horizontalmente
ahora con respecto a mi desplazamiento
horizontal Esto fue el desplazamiento
vertical mi desplazamiento horizontal mi
desplazamiento en el eje de las x es
igual a la velocidad promedio en el eje
de las x que es esto este valor esta
magnitud
multiplicado por
perdón sumado
no no Miento Es el cambio en la
velocidad multiplicado por el cambio en
el tiempo
o la velocidad promedio pero la
velocidad promedio multiplicada por el
cambio en el tiempo el cambio en el
tiempo ya lo encontramos
la velocidad es esta
en x y con esto vamos a calcular el
desplazamiento entonces
mi desplazamiento
es igual a mi velocidad
en el eje x que es 30 coseno de 80
multiplicado por el cambio en el tiempo
que es cinco punto sesenta y siete
segundos multiplicado entonces de nuevo
sacamos nuestra calculadora
limpia el valor
es saco el coseno de 80
lo multiplicó por 30
y lo multiplico por 5.67
y mi resultado es
29.53 metros
29.53 metros de desplazamiento
horizontal quiere decir que desde donde
lancé hasta que cayó fueron
29.53 metros si esto le quito los dos
metros que había entre el suelo y el
inicio de la plataforma pues me queda
que aquí a una distancia sobre la
plataforma fueron
27.53 metros los que se desplazó antes
de caer el proyectil en los vídeos
anteriores no las hemos pasado realmente
descomponiendo vectores pero ahora vamos
a componer un vector a partir de los
elementos horizontales y verticales
vamos a componer el vector
del desplazamiento total
sé que mi desplazamiento horizontal
Bueno este no cambio
bueno es el que es este que tengo que el
desplazamiento es de 29.53 metros
recordando nuestra convención nuestra
convenio ahora
recordando que todas las cantidades que
van hacia la derecha son positivas y las
vectores que van hacia la izquierda son
negativos entonces dibujando nuestros
nuestro desplazamiento horizontal como
vector
este vector
vamos a ponerlo en color magenta
es horizontal y su magnitud es de 29
29.53
nuestro componente vertical fue bueno es
este valor Bueno de hecho nuestro
desplazamiento este al final es este de
10 metros este no cambio porque es la
altura de la plataforma donde cae el
proyectil
Entonces
mi componente aquí es
vale 10 metros
y quiero saber cuál fue el
desplazamiento total entonces pues voy a
sumar estos dos vectores o también lo
puedo calcular con ahora sí que este
los lo que es un las funciones
trigonométricas
conocidas
conozco el cateto Bueno también no
conozco ahorita Cuál es el ángulo
conozco el cateto adyacente y conozco el
cateto opuesto Esto me sirve para
calcular
el valor de la hipotenusa
puedo usar cualquier este cantidad o
usar también el teorema de Pitágoras de
manera que me queda que la magnitud del
vector desplazamiento
al cuadrado va a ser igual al valor de
la magnitud del cateto opuesto
ese
y al cuadrado
más la magnitud
de mi cateto adyacente
al cuadrado
es simplificando me queda que la
magnitud de este vector es igual a la
raíz cuadrada
de la magnitud de este componente
vertical que es 10 al cuadrado más
29.53 que es la magnitud
de la componente horizontal al cuadrado
entonces
es
a
29.53 al cuadrado
lo sumamos 10 al cuadrado es 10 por 10
es 100 lo multiplicamos con 100 y a esto
le sacó la raíz cuadrada y el
desplazamiento esta magnitud viene
siendo igual no me fijé en la cantidad
31 punto
desplazamiento total
31.17 metros Esta es la magnitud de este
vector 31. Ay puse 13 y es 17 17
ahora me falta darle a este vector su
dirección y esto lo puedo hacer
calculando el ángulo entonces aquí es
usando las funciones trigonométricas
puedo usar ya sea el seno el coseno o el
tangente vamos a usar el seno
tenemos que este ángulo lo voy a llamar
teta y el seno de este ángulo va a ser
igual al cateto opuesto
entre la hipotenusa que acabo de
calcular 31.17 para calcular el ángulo
voy a usar el arco seno o el seno
inverso
seno inverso de esta cantidad
y este ángulo o este valor me va a ser
igual a
esto lo pueden calcular ustedes
18.71 grados por encima de la horizontal
18.71 grados entonces si yo dibujo este
vector desplazamiento
es 31 punto 17 de magnitud
con un ángulo de 18 grados
más o menos sería algo así
más o menos el vector desplazamiento
total pero lo que pedíamos en este al
inicio de este vídeo era encontrar el
vector velocidad final o velocidad total
eso lo vamos a ver en el siguiente video